So now that we have our report done with,
we can go to create a Dashboard off of it.
>> Okay, how do I do that?
>> So, if you go back to the top, one of the tabs is Dashboards.
So, we're going to want to create a new Dashboard. And a Dashboard itself is
a layout for a bunch of different dashboard components. And so the report that
we just made is going to create
one dashboard component, which is one Gauge Chart.
>> Okay.
>> And Dashboards can be a culmination
of several dashboard components so you can see
snapshots of a bunch of different stuff at once.
>> Okay. And if I, if my,
>> Intuition is right?
>> Yeah, intuition, that's the word. I'm going to drag some things.
>> Yeah, so drop that guy in, looks just like a little odometer or gauge.
>> Okay, so like a data source here, okay.
>> So the report that we created is
a data source and there are a couple different
data sources you can create, but that's the
easiest one to make, which is point and click.
>> So, I'm going to click Data Source,
open Reports > My Personal Custom Reports. Oh,
wow, this is actually really easy. Isn't this exciting?
>> Yeah, I know, the anticipation is killing me.
>>
[LAUGH]
Hey, cool. Alright so I obviously want to change some of these things.
I want to set some milestones or something. So what should we do?
>> So, the first thing that we need to do, is scroll up and click the Wrench.
>> Oh yeah, always the Wrench.
>> So what we're going is setting the different areas
of the gauge chart so it shows red, yellow, and green.
>> Gotcha.
>> So what's our goal, Andy, for the event?
>> well we've,
we're kind of making this up. Let's say the goal is $200,000.
>> Sounds good.
>> so then that's, well that'll be the yellow
to green threshold, let's say. So that we then, if
we make more on that, we can still see
it go beyond that. I'm going to make this one 300,000.
>> Okay, and so then that red would be 100,000. Yup.
>> Oh, cool.
>> So usually these thresholds would be based off of real metrics.
>> Yeah.
>> In this case we just made it up but you can see where the progress is on
the right. And there's actually, it turns into a
smaller number in order to make it fit. And so
it says 100, 200, 300 but you can see the sum of the total spent is really in
the thousands here. Now if you go to the
Component Data you can change how it's showing this gauge.
>> I can do Whole Units, and then it overlaps and it looks crappy so we'll
do, I think thousands is fine.
>> Thousands looks good. you can also change the value
so maybe you don't want track the actually total spent.
Maybe you just want to spent, see how many different records
there were. if you, I mean we don't in this case.
>> No
>> But I'm just saying, like there, there are option here for you
to be able to work with the same rapport but display different data.
>> Okay, cool. And so let's pretend, if this were
a real festival. The, this first threshold, 100,000, would be like,
that's your cost, that's just recuperating your cost. Maybe 200,000
is your goal, and then that's a bonus or something.
>> But really, immediately, we see off of those like couple hundred records,
hey, we have a lot more to go before we hit our goal.
>> Okay, that's pretty cool.